so we've been talking about jacksonian
democracy and when we last left off
Andrew Jackson had defeated John Quincy
Adams in the election of 1828 largely by
claiming that Quincy Adams had won the
previous election through a corrupt
bargain so Jackson played upon the
sympathies of the public by claiming
that he was the common man or the
representation of the common man he took
advantage of the growing number of white
male voters who could participate in
elections and particularly the growing
numbers of frontier settlers who not
only wanted to vote for the first
president to be born in the West also
supported Jackson because he was known
for his anti Native American sentiment
and his promise to remove Native
Americans from lands that White's wanted
to settle east of the Mississippi so in
the first video in this series I
mentioned that most scholars point to
this moment of Jackson's election in
1828 as the beginning of modern
democracy so let's investigate some of
those claims a little bit further so
what was it about Jackson's election and
presidency that began the modern
American political system well for one
thing Jackson was the very first
Democratic president has in the first
president to be a modern-day Democrat
and this is the same Democratic Party
that we still have today and Jackson
really mobilized this sentiment of the
party of the common man and in his idea
that meant the common white man that he
was not one of these Eastern elites
banking elites who made their fortunes
by nickel and diming other people
he was backwoods frontiersman a war hero
someone who
had pulled himself up by his bootstraps
so he was I guess one of the earliest
self-made men and it was clear from the
get-go that the age of Jackson was going
to be a completely different kind of
political culture than had existed
previously because at his inauguration
he had a giant inaugural celebration he
opened up the White House to anybody
the rabble came in and he trashed the
place
and the older aristocratic class of
Washington politicians thought that this
was more or less the end of the Republic
as they knew it this was going to be the
era of mob rule but you know the wheels
didn't come off democracy and one thing
that Jackson really did was he rewarded
his supporters he rewarded the people
who had voted Democrat who saw
themselves as part of the Democratic
Party with government positions and this
is called the spoils system along the
lines of to the victor go the spoils so
to reward the Democratic machine that
had put him in office he kicked out
earlier office holders and rewarded the
Democrats with offices it was very
common in this time period for people to
be or known as office seekers to kind of
hang out in Washington DC trying to get
the President to appoint you postmaster
of some random place so that you could
draw a government salary now earlier
presidents would have thought something
like rewarding an office seeker quite
vulgar John Quincy Adams for example
refused to replace anyone who was
actually doing a good job in their
government post with someone who was one
of his supporters so you can debate
or not this is actually a good thing to
kick out people who are good at their
job in favor of people who have
supported you during the campaign but
what it does is it keeps people in the
party so it makes sure that even if the
party loses they know that they have put
in their labor for the Democratic Party
and later for the Whig and Republican
Party and so they're going to keep
working to put their candidate in office
so that they can reap some rewards so
this is one way in which Jackson kind of
solidifies Party politics so that you
stop just being a Jackson partisan a
Jefferson partisan someone who follows a
political candidate and remember that
earlier political candidates kind of
stood as men of virtue right now the
virtue is shifting from the men
themselves to the party that they
represent and this party system was
cemented by 1832 when Jackson was
reelected when they held a national
nominating convention sounds very
familiar to us today and put out an
official party platform so what else did
Jackson do that was really influential
Oh ironically for someone billing
himself as a man of the people
Jackson worked really hard to expand the
power of the executive branch so he
wanted the presidency to be as powerful
if not more powerful than the judicial
branch or the legislative branch of the
United States so more powerful than a
Supreme Court or Congress there were two
major instances where he shows his
interest in becoming the most powerful
part of the American government one of
these was and what
known as the bank war when Jackson
attempted to kill the Bank of the United
States and he succeeded because he
thought that the National Bank was
corrupt that it benefited the elite that
it deserved more oversight from the
federal government some of which was
true and when Congress tried to
recharter the National Bank he vetoed
the Charter basically saying that he
felt that his vote was more important
than the vote of Congress and for this a
group of people who started to coalesce
around their hatred for Jackson started
calling him King Andrew the first
because Jackson used the power of the
veto all the time because he was trying
to in some ways reduce the power of the
federal government which was one of the
key tenants of the Democratic Party but
at the same time kind of increased his
own power because he used his veto in
many cases to further his own agenda
and as much as the National Bank was not
a great institution it did help to keep
the United States's economy more or less
humming along and once Jackson killed it
there was a major economic depression
called the panic of 1837 which we can
lay pretty much squarely at Jackson's
feet you can see this political cartoon
here has him trampling on the
Constitution as he pushes his own agenda
forward and it's through their hatred of
Jackson that a new group comes together
the Whig party which will provide the
second half of the two-party system that
comes to the fore in this time period so
this is Andrew Jackson arguing that the
president has more power than Congress
there's a second example of Andrew
Jackson trying to argue that he had more
power than the Supreme Court which comes
in the Trail of Tears
so Andrew Jackson represented the
interests of white settlers who really
saw Native Americans as no more than an
obstacle to their continuous push
westward the availability of lands which
they saw really as the cornerstone of
American prosperity and I can't do
justice to the entire Trail of Tears
here we have an article about that and
there'll be more to come in the future
but suffice it to say that the American
Indians who were living in Georgia
particularly and who were known as the
Five Civilized tribes because they had
adopted many of the ways of Europeans
including Christianity and in some cases
slavery the Supreme Court ruled that
they were entitled to be treated as a
sovereign nation and so when Georgia is
trying to remove Native Americans from
their lands in Georgia the Chief Justice
of the Supreme Court John Marshall rules
in their favor and Andrew Jackson was
quoted as saying John Marshall has made
his decision
now let him enforce it so even though
the Supreme Court defended the status of
the Native Americans living in Georgia
east of the Mississippi in general
Andrew Jackson in the state of Georgia
went ahead with forcing the Five
Civilized tribes to move westward to
Oklahoma during which at least 3,000
people died so Andrew Jackson serves a
second term and finishes out his
presidency in 1836 he considered running
for a third term decided against it
instead his crony Martin Van Buren was
basically Andrew Jackson jr.
serves as president for one term but due
to the panic of 1837 martin van buren
like poor herbert hoover later is forced
to deal with an economic depression and
you know that people are never happy
with the incumbent president when
there's an economic decline so in the
election of 1840 the Whigs the
opposition party to Andrew Jackson run
William Henry Harrison as their
candidate and he is mostly famous for
being a fellow who died in office after
only 40 days but what's interesting
about William Henry Harrison's campaign
is that the Whigs have learned their
lesson about the political climate of
the Jacksonian age they marketed William
Henry Harrison as having been born in a
log cabin a war hero he was a man of the
people just a common guy who had pulled
himself up by his bootstraps now none of
this was true William Henry Harrison was
from Virginia he was from a very wealthy
family he had been college-educated he
was no more rough-and-tumble than John
Quincy Adams had been but the Whigs had
learned a valuable lesson about what
American political culture was like in
the age of mass democracy and from this
point forward it's clear that Americans
don't like their politicians too
highfalutin and woe betide any candidate
who wasn't born in a log cabin
the modern American political system had
begun